roll up t-shirt something happen in here
what it is ain't exactly clear there's a
man with our gun over there I telling me
I got to stop children what's that sound
what's wrong
and the history of politics of the
United States there has never been
anything like this they call it a
phenomena human a phenomena we're all a
phenomena here a phenomena
this is no ordinary presidential
election even in the land where money
talks and everything is bigger 2016 is
proving to be a showstopper center stage
is America's most famous rich man Donald
Trump property tycoon reality TV star
best-selling author for years he's
projected an image of wealth and success
relentlessly promoting his deal maker
extraordinaire persona now Donald Trump
is selling himself to the American
people with his sights set on the most
powerful office in the world ladies and
gentlemen I am officially running for
president of the United States
and we are going to make our country
great again
I've been following the Trump circus for
months now what began as a joke has
become the most extraordinary political
campaign of modern times
baffling politicians and enthralling his
supporters he speaks for the people
who's he saying I've been saying for
years when he wins we all win how does
he make you feel inside when you here
race me feeling sorry makes me feel like
I just want to just I'm bursting for joy
than we possibly have a chance to bring
the America that our forefathers wanted
us to have the freedom free so much
freedom has been taken away from us
we're like slaves here we're gonna make
our country so great we are going to
make it strong we are going to make it
powerful we're gonna rebuild the
military we're gonna make it so strong I
will be the greatest jobs president that
God ever created I tell you that you're
gonna win for the country we're gonna
win win win Trump's campaign is
spontaneous it's a grassroots uprising
it's an insurrection it's an insurgency
it's a revolt against the established
order
they don't have to call voters and tell
them to turn out for Donald Trump
they're turning out on their own
this is a natural phenomena and I've
never seen anything like it
in American politics
he's giving people a level of emotional
satisfaction that you really don't get
anywhere else in politics when you go to
a Ted Cruz or Marco Rubio event and you
hear a sort of dry proper speech about
policy it's not the same sort of almost
vaudeville act that you're getting at a
Donald Trump's show but there's a dark
side to Donald Trump's presidential bid
to get himself elected Trump is
exploiting America's simmering social
tensions when Mexico sends its people
they're not sending their best they're
not sending you they're not sending you
they're sending people that have lots of
problems they're bringing drugs they're
bringing crime they're rapists I want
surveillance of certain mosques okay if
that's okay Donald J Trump is calling
for a total and complete shutdown of
Muslims entering the United States until
our country's representatives can figure
out what the hell is going on
the idea of it would be having a black
president meant that we were beyond
racial divisions that the race didn't
matter in the way that it you know or
that the problems of racism were smaller
and more manageable than they had been
in the past and that there weren't
people who were sort of openly racist in
our public discourse I think that you
have to say that's wrong I think he has
a very very good sense of what resonates
with his audience so when he starts to
talk about something and he sees people
respond to it he'll see him start to
incorporate that and and he's very
clever he says what a lot of people are
thinking and he doesn't worry about
saying it straightforward he says he
speaks his mind and people like that I
think about how successful he has been
at negotiating and leading and all the
things it takes to be a good leader in
his field and I just I just see him
being able to do that with our country
so you caught Donald Trump's eye I did I
mean he pointed to me I was in the back
he pointed he goes you and I just I was
just like a little schoolgirl just I
felt very special and so this is very
very important to us and what was what
was it like being up close and personal
with the dog trust like a dream come
true I mean he just I mean I swear it's
like a girl a schoolgirl crush but it's
like I have watched him on Celebrity
Apprentice forever I have always admired
the fact that he's not afraid to say
what everybody else is thinking he's
just so independent and this is a
candidate that I actually believe in I
have never ever wanted someone to be
president so bad in my life I'm
essentially evolutional about it how do
you but his food I don't know it's
almost like I know him I mean it and I
don't but I feel like that I know him
and I've watched him and I listen to the
things he says and I hear all these
criticisms what about as a woman he said
some pretty nasty things about women in
the past he's rated them out of Ted he's
called the pigs and dogs and does that
bother you
why do I because I mean I've you know so
things about women I mean everybody
that's the thing is everybody has said
something about somebody or something
that's not flattering but not everybody
wants to be President is it presidential
to speak that way um is it politically
correct
no but that's what's so perfect about
him he's not worried about being
politically correct he owns whatever he
does live in Mississippi I hate to say
there's a lot of wealth in Mississippi
we know that got a lot of wealthy people
you have some people however that are
not doing so well because their jobs are
being taken away their jobs are going to
foreign lands and we're not going to let
that happen anymore folks
we're not going
is it tough working hard reading off a
little girl and how's life is it EDIS is
painful I mean to be honest with you
because I see her and honestly and I
always say this I've always wanted to
give her the life of like Donald Trump
I mean of anybody any of the celebrities
you know I mean as a mother you want
that and me so more than anybody I mean
it's just something like like I love
money I love like the huge lifestyles I
can't give that to my child so it's hard
but I don't live beyond my means I'm the
type of person I pay my bills I think
that that's the most important thing do
you feel like with him in charge that
could somehow how would it impact you
yes I feel like well I think that he
will start making decisions for this
country that will help out this country
because we have a great country we have
great people and these people want to
see America be great again that's what
they want what they want now a lot of
times people they go to the poll they
don't know anything about the person
they're voting for and I used to be that
way I mean I would you know well this
person is this and but I didn't really
get to know what they were behind what
they believed in the things that they
were about you feel like you know don't
do I really do I mean I and I guess
might be foolishly because I've watched
him on the Celebrity Apprentice or in
news all over the world and just I've
seen his children be interviewed and
different things and it's just the way
it carries himself the way the things
that he's done the things that I mean
he's not afraid to stand up for himself
do you have any reservations about
Donald Trump
I really don't not at all I'm just I
really don't I mean I think that he is
going to be a breath of fresh air
Oh
welcome to America in 2016 where the
atmosphere is charged with anger and
exclusion get him out of here get him
out get him out of you
when he stands up and says get him out
of here and I'd like to punch him in the
face and in flames a crowd I love the
old days you know what they used to do
to guys like that when they were in a
place like this they'd be carried out on
a stretcher folks he's not considering
whether someone could get hurt and he's
not considering whether he's inspiring
hatred like to punch him in the face
I'll tell you he gets very angry he gets
very angry and we see that actually on
the campaign trail when there are
protestors get out get out of here get
him out get him out troublemaker get him
out of here I think he's tapped into a
mentality of racism of sexism of
separatism of divisive 'no stand of laid
not dormant but has been unspoken
in the politically correct society that
we've created an american
the anti-trump protests became bigger
and bolder after he received the support
of the Ku Klux Klan there's also like a
lot of anger and it's not just sort of
people who come to admire Donald Trump
it's people who are angry at somebody
else it feels like Donald Trump projects
that anger at the right people I think
these are people who came of age in a
time when white people were the
unquestioned dominant force in American
politics on both sides of the Berlin
conservative and so I think part of make
America great again is a call back to a
time when that was sort of who got to
say what went on
any person who drapes themselves in the
flag and stands up and says I love
America and creates enemies for people
to gather against will inspire some
excitement
what is campaigning from what I can tell
it's going around the country in his
trunk plane and talking to people okay
he talks to people and he gets them
riled up that's me is a very very
dangerous game to play because you were
eventually going to reap what you sow
and if you're sowing divisive nasur
going to reap the outcomes of devices
and we've seen but that leads to in our
country already he clearly cannot handle
not being adored by everyone part of the
problem and part of the reason it takes
so long is nobody wants to hurt each
other anymore right and they're being
politically correct the way they take
them out so it takes a little bit longer
and honestly protesters they realize it
they realize that there are no
consequences to protesting anymore there
used to be consequences there are none
anymore
24 hours news Mississippi I'm Laurie
Thompson with what you need to know this
hour in parts of the United States
struggling to recover from the economic
recession Donald Trump's promise of
prosperity is powerful as mayor Johnny
Dupree told local WDM people who live
near water should not rest in a lot in
they become
Shane Humphries is willing to forgive
his imperfections so the way he's
behaved and some of the things he said
you haven't liked but you're still going
to vote for him agree that's fair only
because if we're looking for the perfect
candidate Republican Democrat we're all
going to be able to nitpick the faults
there's never going to be anybody that
puts a checkbox in every category at the
end of the day I just want a president
that's going to treat our country as a
as a business model with hopes that my
children and their children can reap the
benefits you know long after I'm gone
what we've all seen within the last two
or three months of the antics not just
with him but with everybody involved I
think it it can rub anybody the wrong
way
is it presidential the way he pays not
all the time I think that there's
moments that can be viewed as
presidential then there's moments that
would be fit for a true reality show and
and I think that's part of the appeal
and I think that's the one reservation
that that we have probably everybody has
is is how will that fit in the White
House and I don't know that anybody
really has that answer
so many of Trump supporters think that
his success in business is directly
transferable to government
Donald way back and when he first
started in the 80s came up with the idea
that he could brand real estate well
that was unheard of because buildings
were owned by these companies that no
one had ever heard of and Donald said no
I'm going to create a brand it's going
to be called Trump century don't want
something mean to it do it better than
anybody you ever seen do it streusel
lady
Donald Trump wants the world to marvel
at his Midas touch the decades he's
quoted the public perception of fabulous
wealth it's essential to his brand it's
also deeply personal Forbes magazine
compiles an annual list showing the net
worth of the world's wealthiest people
there are many billionaires who dispute
but there is nobody in more than 30
years of doing this who cares more about
what Forbes says their net worth is then
Donald Trump nobody so this is the
wealth desk what happens here this is
the full-time team that tries to figure
out how much every rich person in the
world is worth to a very small decimal
point
forbes has him at 4.5 billion he says
he's worth over 10 billion was worth the
discrepancy Trump argues that his brand
just his name alone has a theoretical
value of 3 billion dollars you plop on
top of that now when you start just
conjuring three billion dollars for your
name you can make yourself be worth a
lot of money
so getting the Trump gig guys is that
the poison chalice or the Welcome job
you know I think it's a little bit of
both it's a really good opportunity to
to figure out you know what makes the
man tick and you know and what his
assets you know really are but it's also
a lot of work you know he certainly owns
a lot of things step they telling the
truth there and you got to meet it you
got to be in a room with other say look
mr. Trump this is what I think about
what your work I know well I don't know
if I even had that much
he's not curious he's not engaged he's
you know he starts every day with a
sheaf of printouts where his name is
circled or highlighted and that's his
reading for the day to me
four billion 10 billion either way
you're very successful but there is
clearly something in him that drives him
and that you know this is a major I mean
you know the force for 100 and our
Forbes billionaires list you know it's a
way to measure yourself against other
very successful people and clear this is
somebody who's very driven by where he
ranks in the world and on our list easy
worth 2 billion or 5 billion or 10
billion does it matter
I don't think it matters the point is he
has been successful you know if you're a
shark moving through the water eating
everything in sight and leaving a bloody
trail behind you you're pretty
successful and Donald Trump is a shark
moving steadily through the water and
never looking back he consumes
everything that he comes upon and leaves
the bloody mess behind and it doesn't
matter at all to him Donald Trump's
self-promotion went into overdrive when
he turned himself into a reality star
watched by millions the timing of The
Apprentice and of him hosting The
Apprentice could not have been better
for Donald one man who knows all about
the strange power of reality television
is former apprentice winner
Randall Pinkett
I mean the Richard Branson there's
others who have this elevated status but
but but to have the stage of The
Apprentice really did elevate Donald to
a level that was unprecedent for him and
for for most entrepreneurs
same is true for us who competed who
were largely unknowns it gave us that
same platform that's given down and
because we now value celebrity the way
that we do that we almost blindly
subscribe to the views of celebrities
it's given America an Achilles heel that
says well celebrities don't always have
the right answers levers aren't always
qualified for what they endeavor to do
but that seems a trunk no pun intended
any other qualification nowadays now
Steve Burke of Comcast great guy came up
to my office with the people at NBC
please Donald would like you to do the
apprentice the ratings after 14 seasons
were still fantastic they were still
great and I said Steve I think I'm gonna
run for president no no no you're not
you're not no I think I'm going to run
for president that they didn't want me
to they wanted me to because the show
does great in his latest incarnation as
host of The Apprentice he was in
millions of American homes every week
really for 14 years so he established
this persona he doesn't really have to
do this for the fame or fortune or any
of it doing it because he loves his
country
and we love him or him 100% you know you
just are so thankful that someone will
stand up and say what they really mean
and say what I think is the voice of
many people in this country
you're a lifelong Democrat and now
you're going to vote for Donald try I'm
gonna vote for Donald Trump
you know we're Americans we've always in
our lifetime then looked up to as the
leaders of this world they don't do that
no more
they laugh at us but Donald Trump can
change that I believe he can
Friday the 11th of March Donald Trump is
due to take to the stage for a campaign
event mr. Trump just arrived in Chicago
and after meeting with law enforcement
has determined that for the safety of
all the tens of thousands of people that
have gathered in and around the arena
tonight's rally will be postponed until
another day thank you very much for your
attendance and please go in peace
what followed was a trump rally like no
other hundreds of protestors clashed
with his supporters
the big diverse city of Chicago was far
less welcoming and his usual stops in
America's white suburbs I felt like I
was getting a glimpse of what the
sixties looked like
I was unsafe I knew that my life was in
danger but I also knew my future was and
I was shocked so what he gave my mission
became to get on that stage and put the
message out that needs to be heard
what were you saying when you wrote that
so I brought it to the stage I jumped
over the rim
I said America is already great without
hate
I'm better than Chicago
I will not tolerate this kind of
rhetoric being on Chicago soil or in
Chicago's Airways
these ugly scenes confirmed the
political elites worst fears the Trump
phenomenon was beyond their control for
Republican activists this is an annual
Jamboree
CPAC is the Conservative Political
Action Conference Glastonbury for the
grassroots Trump was due to do a
headline speech here but he pulled out
at the last minute the Republicans of
the party that gave America George Bush
actor turned President Ronald Reagan
even Abraham Lincoln but never in their
illustrious history have they had to
deal with a Donald Trump what do you
make of Donald Trump do I have to be
honest here in this Donald Trump I think
he's a recipe the guarantee lost in the
election he will never win the
presidency even even against a very
flawed Democratic candidate in Hillary
Clinton he has no credibility or
integrity in my eyes as a concern
so I like to vote for someone based on
their principles and based on their
background and not based on what they're
saying we've spoken to quite a few C
Packers and you are the first one who
said that they like Donald Trump I
realize it why don't the Republican
establishment like Donald ha well it's
amazing how popular he is though isn't
it and the more that he insults people
and makes a semi sad or something the
more successful he gets because people
are tired of the way things have gone
everybody's going to help you
everybody's going to do you Congress is
going to do this get them in nobody does
anything once they're in they don't know
how to fight anymore they give up what
we've seen in the past is that
Republicans have tended to pick sort of
the next guy in line someone who's run
before or say the son or the brother of
a former president but someone who had
sort of past those establishment markers
and litmus test and someone who was
relatively moderate someone like Florida
Senator Marco Rubio
being a conservative cannot simply be
about how long you're willing to scream
how angry you're willing to be or how
many names are willing to call people
that is not conservative as Donald
Trump's playing by his own rules
he's self funding his campaign for the
most part he's picking and choosing
which media appearances which debates
which conference appearances he wants to
go to rather than tip making its
decisions in tandem with the Republican
establishment so of course they feel
left out they don't want that to be you
know they don't want a candidate who
they don't have some control over but if
the choice is going to be Donald Trump
or Hillary Clinton it would only be
smart for the Republican Party and
idiotic not to coalesce behind someone
who's running opposite Hillary Clinton
an assault was launched the goal
bringing down Donald Trump Trump's
partner on hotel deals had an ecstasy
trafficking record Trump entrusted
convicts to help him run his company he
praises Putin doesn't know what our
nuclear weapons triad is says he'd be
neutral between Israel and its enemies
is not what he appears to be Donald
Trump is a phony stop him now
Republicans were in denial for a long
time they thought that this was a
phenomenon that would be a passing fancy
and would flame out on its own and they
wouldn't have to do anything there was
also a collective action problem there
were so many candidates in the race none
of them thought it was his job to take
out Trump the establishment big gun was
brought out to do his worst will you
please join me in welcoming governor
Mitt Romney
I'm far from the first to conclude that
Donald Trump lacks the temperament to be
President after all this is an
individual who mocked a disabled
reporter you got to see this guy ah I
don't know what I said ah I don't
remember he inherited his business he
didn't create it and whatever happened
to trump Airlines how about Trump
University and then there's Trump
magazine a business genius he is not
I built a company that's worth more than
ten billion dollars watch by the way how
he responds to my speech today I mean
honestly I took I'll just address it
quickly because it's irrelevant this may
tell you what you need to know about his
temperament mitt is a failed candidate
he failed his stability he was begging
for my endorsement and his suitability
to be president I could have said mitt
drop to your knees he would have dropped
to his knees Donald Trump is a phony a
fraud his promises are as worthless as a
degree from Trump University
for Republicans a lot of tutors
Republican establishment types you know
the consultants the intelligencia the
lobbyists the donors the people who
thought they ran the Republican Party
this has been profoundly disillusioning
because the things that they thought the
Republican Party stood for the
conservative principles that are the
reason that they fight this fight turn
out not to be the things that their
voters are interested in
he's been pro-choice he's been pro-life
he's been for an assault weapons ban
he's been against an assault weapons ban
is he inconsistent and I don't consider
it inconsistent I consider it having a
freedom to change your mind at any given
opportunity and we're all allowed that
does it bother you that he's changed his
political stance on issues over the
years not really no because all the
politicians do that anyways I mean look
at Obama he said he's going to do all
the stuff he got officer and he's almost
crippled America
he says he's funding his own campaign
arguably that's not strictly true
he's loaning money to his campaign that
he can get back and that's good at least
he's not getting money from other
politicians and people that can tell him
what he's going to do and what he's not
going to do to run his campaign he is
taking donations from people since we
know they can donate on his website oh
yeah you can donate on his website but
he's not taking big big money from big
lobbyists and stuff of that nature
in these towns in the American heartland
that used to have factories but the
factories have moved away and person
after person that you talk to they lost
their job at the plant when it got
bought by a foreign company and all the
jobs went away you get to show your
friends you don't want to make the best
decision today he's referring to a time
that those people can remember when life
was better for them and that's a very
powerful force so when he talks about
being able to win again these are people
who feel sort of personally kicked
around by society and they like that
idea that we can win make a wish you
know help mama push the button he's
going to make a decision that is what's
best for us he's going to stop letting
other countries dictate you know
everything he's just going to put a stop
he you know we finally have somebody to
stand up to the bullies I truly believe
that he is the only choice
you excited I will be excited too when
he wins
gentlemen once again flight-deck
good morning to you we just down the
street I'm on the campaign trail
following Donald Trump right across
America he's won state after state
edging closer to becoming the Republican
choice for president
ladies and gentlemen it is my honor my
privilege to introduce to you the next
president of the United States Donald J
Trump when he starts to talk you don't
know what's going to happen and you
can't look away that's not true of most
political candidates these days Trump's
events feel more like rock concerts with
adoring crowds crying out for his
greatest hits build that wall build that
wall gonna be built who's gonna pay for
the war Mexico Honduras
I represent there's something exciting
about this this is why we like action
movies and and they rack up huge sums at
the box office that pure emotion turned
into action is really exciting in a
world where everything is nuanced and
difficult and complex and I can see the
appeal a major driver of the Trump
phenomenon is his outsider status he
isn't part of the political elite I'm
self-funding my own campaign I'm putting
up my own money
when that big plane flies into Ohio
you know it's paying for Trump is paying
for it not a special interest I paid for
a very interesting aspect of Trump's
appeal is that he is running against not
just the establishment but against the
lobbyists and donors that are perceived
as running the Republican Party schools
I also think people like the fact that
he is unfolding to any special-interest
because he is wealthy because he is self
financing his campaign Trump Trump is an
entertainer first of all that sort of
his business but he also may be a
reaction by the public to how controlled
and choreographed and stale so much of
our politics has become that Trump is
not taking sophisticated polls to tell
him what to say to be popular all he's
doing speaking from the heart but it
comes at a time when the American people
are particularly frustrated I'm tired of
the politicians in Washington I'm tired
of the way the country is being run and
I want some change I want somebody new
and the man knows what he's doing we're
tired of being lied to cheated on and
everything else from the from the
mainstream politicians and we're just
fed up with all that kind of BS out of
Washington yeah I think most people are
probably attracted to his campaign
because the fact that he's not a
politician he's totally not in the fold
and he's he's independent of of the
establishment so he he feels and this is
his showmanship he can say whatever he
wants and get away with it and it's
pretty amazing it's quite a show the
reason they're so frustrated is they
expected great things from Barack Obama
he promised us hope and change but in
fact nothing has changed and we're less
hopeful than we've ever been before
he became Barack Obama's chief tormentor
promoting this horrible campaign where
people questioned whether he was an
American citizen
our current president came out of
nowhere
came out of nowhere in fact I'm gonna
step further the people that went to
school with him they don't even know
they never saw him they don't know who
he is crazy
he had this visceral animosity where
Obama was concerned I also think he was
ambitious politically from the start of
his life somebody who cares a lot about
Fame and attention and being a celebrity
and he got into this I think as people
people he'd flirted with it people said
no you can't do it in fact in 2011 when
he was flirting with it before the last
presidential election the President
Obama like locked him in a dinner with
all the Washington elite in the room
Donald Trump tomorrow
now I know that he's taken some flak
lately but no one is happier no one is
prouder to put this birth certificate
matter to rest than the Donald and
that's because he can finally get back
to focusing on the issues that matter it
made fun of him in front of his hair in
front of his tan in front of his career
on reality television no seriously just
recently in an episode of Celebrity
Apprentice at the steakhouse the men's
cooking team did not impress the judges
from Omaha Steaks and there was a lot of
blame to go around but you mr. Trump
recognized that the real problem was a
lack of leadership and these are the
kind of decisions that would keep me up
at night and I think he felt
disrespected and and so started his
campaign just to show those people that
he could do it
Trump's suitability for the White House
is no longer just a punchline it's the
talk of America Florida lawyer
Elizabeth Beck represented clients
through a suing Trump for a failed
property venture I had just given birth
to my firstborn child she was three
months at that time I pulled out my
medela bag looks like a woman's handbag
okay and I said I need a break
because I need to breast pump okay and I
said this in a room full of men there
was no other women there and when I said
that mr. Trump stood in front of me
about a foot and a half and he just
started screaming at me okay his he he
shook his fingers at me and started
screaming he said you're disgusting
you're disgusting
and then he just turned around and he
ran out of there he just turned tail and
he ran and his bodyguard ran after him
and he was gone how would you describe
his temperament in a professional
setting his temperament is um he's uh
he's touchy he's insecure I think he's
uh I think he's a fearful person finding
the flaws in Trump's record and campaign
is easy what's difficult is getting them
to stick a new study from the
immigration policy Center says there's
no correlation between immigrants and
violent crime why should America trust a
man who ignores the fact to push a
message of fear well one of the things I
want to do and I feel very strongly it's
a country based on borders and our
country is based on laws and when people
come into the country illegally we
should not allow that the populist
billionaire can talk his way out of
anything and people don't just buy it
they embrace it and we'll get out
knocking door-to-door I'll do whatever I
can and I will be honestly thankful that
we have a president I Donald Ron finally
you're gonna be proud of your president
you're gonna be so proud of your country
I wrote him off summer of 2015
I grew concerned in the fall of 2015 and
here welcome to 2016 private
worried tell your friends vote for Trump
I promise you I am gonna do such a great
job
the idea of president Donald J Trump
terrifies me are you ready for this
folks are you ready
Donald Trump is defining this election
whether or not he makes it all the way
to the White House 2016 will be
remembered as a year when America
witnessed a political rebellion you will
look back two years from now ten years
from now 20 years from now you're going
to say that's the single greatest vote I
ever cast Donald Trump be President of
the United States god forbid but I'm
fighting against it not just for Chicago
or Illinois or America I'm fighting
against it for the world
I would hate for you all to have to deal
with him as our president
it is a magical and historic moment we
have to figure out folks what the hell
is going on this is an example of the
times meeting the man this is this is
this is kismet this is this is a a this
is a perfect moment a perfect storm if
you will you get to the end you can
handle a lot of things including
pressure I think he wants to be
President because it's the job that is
the greatest and would suggest that he
truly is the great man that he claims to
be and you think I had such an easy life
what do I need this for right
you